[Música]
hola que tal como están supongo que
ustedes lo habrán pensado alguna vez
porque hay algunos aparatos alrededor
nuestro que nos ayudan en la vida
cotidiana pero que si lo pensamos un
poco son algo que diría yo
estúpidos un poquito no vamos a pensarlo
imagínense una noche entre semana
acabamos una cena de trabajo a las
tantas y vamos con nuestro coche por una
avenida que tiene 45 carriles y allí no
hay nadie pero sí que está el típico
semáforo enorme con su disco rojo y
nosotros obedientes paramos
y esperamos
y esperamos y no viene nadie no hay
ningún peatón ningún coche y seguimos
esperando yo no piensas vamos a ver no
puedes saber el semáforo que no pasa
nadie no podría ponerse en verde que
tengo que llegar a mi casa que tengo
sueño que mañana madrugo y el semáforo
no nos mantiene ahí esperando y saben
por qué porque el semáforo es estúpido
el semáforo no sabe qué es lo que sucede
a su alrededor es un automatismo y
cambia de color según un ciclo
preestablecido cuando todos ustedes se
van de madrid en agosto no es una
leyenda los semáforos siguen funcionando
a pesar de que parece que no hay nadie
se dan cuenta que sería un semáforo
inteligente bueno no hay objetos que
sean ellos por sí solos inteligentes un
semáforo inteligente necesitaría un
montón de sensores a su alrededor que le
dieran información sobre la realidad y
con estos datos sí que podría
interactuar
si esto lo miramos en grande y pensamos
en una ciudad inteligente una ciudad
inteligente es en primer lugar una
cantidad ingente de sensores por todas
partes que ofrecen información con el
objetivo de mejorar nuestra calidad de
vida a partir de tres criterios orden
eficacia y sostenibilidad y sobre todo
lo que tiene es que son capaces de
interactuar con el entorno y de recoger
estos datos a una velocidad increíble a
una velocidad velocidad que el ser
humano no puede ni siquiera soñar
ustedes saben que no les estoy hablando
de ciencia ficción con el 5 g hemos
superado una barrera el 5g es 20 veces
más rápido que la tecnología 4g ya
impresionante que teníamos hasta ahora
pero lo que es casi más importante su
velocidad de latencia su capacidad de
reacción es casi instantánea y esto
realmente es lo que lo que va a
cambiarlo todo y ahora si ahora
tendremos el coche autónomo y tendremos
ciudades inteligentes que gestionen el
tráfico la calidad del agua la calidad
del aire los servicios de seguridad los
servicios sanitarios prácticamente todo
siguiendo tres pasos primero recoger un
montón de datos
segundo enviarlos a ordenadores que lo
procesan muy rápidamente y en tercer
lugar y quizá lo más importante
reaccionar buscando esa eficacia y
mejorar nuestra calidad de vida
se imaginan
pensemos por ejemplo en los servicios de
emergencia los servicios de emergencia
conocerían de manera inmediata el punto
exacto en el momento preciso en el que
se ha producido un accidente y podrían
actuar muy rápido es más si nosotros
contamos en nuestro organismo con
sensores interconectados como ya sucede
con algunas personas por motivos de
salud cuando las ambulancias fueran
hacia ese punto concreto tendrían
información para saber exactamente cómo
tienen que reaccionar y actuarían
verdaderamente de una manera muy eficaz
y muy veloz
se imaginan se imaginan cuántas vidas se
van a poder salvar con estos sistemas
inteligentes realmente es algo
emocionante el futuro que nos espera en
los próximos años para mí es muy
ilusionante y estoy muy contento de
poder verlo y lo vemos constantemente en
la radio en la televisión en la prensa
pero hoy no les voy a hablar de esto
hoy les voy a hablar de otro aspecto de
otro aspecto de esta realidad
maravillosa que también tenemos que
pensar y tener presente si queremos
conseguir que las ciudades inteligentes
sean algo grande que mejoren nuestra
vida
empecemos por ejemplo volvamos otra vez
al tráfico porque el tráfico es una
realidad para nosotros muy cotidiana
cuánto tiempo perdemos o gastamos al
volante o cuántos atascos tenemos que
sufrir en las calles y en las carreteras
que tenemos actualmente bueno pues me
atrevo a darles una buena noticia no es
la única que voy a dar hoy pero está
buena los atascos tal y como los
conocemos con las ciudades inteligentes
prácticamente podemos afirmar que van a
desaparecer
porque cuando estos ordenadores que
gestionan el trafico sepan hacia dónde
vamos a qué hora tenemos que llegar o
queremos llegar y conozcan el estado de
todas las calles de la ciudad o de las
carreteras nos van a llevar hasta
nuestro destino de la manera más rápida
y más segura va a ser una mejora
increíble
ahora bien tendrán ustedes que entender
que para conseguir esa mejora
hay que eliminar un factor importante
que india decisivo a la hora de conducir
ya se imagina en verdad los conductores
porque nosotros no tendemos a ser
eficaces no tenemos esa tendencia a
mirar el bien común y cuando el semáforo
se pone en naranja a veces en verde
freno pisamos el acelerador ya que está
muy cerca verdad que si lo hacemos mucho
nos colamos sobre frenamos tenemos que
aceptarlo si queremos que el tráfico sea
verdaderamente eficaz
vamos a tener que dejar que la
inteligencia artificial lleve el
vehículo en lugar de nosotros y bueno
tampoco está grave porque ese tiempo lo
vamos a poder emplear el er en jugar con
nuestros hijos en ver la televisión en
mirar el móvil bueno eso ya lo hacemos
pero está mal y no hay que hacerlo no
entonces podremos hacerlo
sin embargo hay que mirar un poco más
allá
miren carolina osorio es una
investigadora del instituto tecnológico
de massachusetts que está trabajando en
la gestión del tráfico inteligente de
algunas zonas de nueva york y tiene una
idea que va más allá y muchos
científicos la siguen y en la siguiente
voy a intentar explicarlo con un ejemplo
supongan que ustedes van a tener un
encuentro de trabajo un jueves a las 8
de la tarde al otro lado de la m-30
tienen un problema
y van a contribuir a que el tráfico de
la ciudad vaya peor se van a cruzar con
un montón de vehículos y si todas las
agendas de todos los ciudadanos de
madrid y alrededores estuvieran
interconectadas y este ordenador pudiera
decir mira muchacho tú estás loco el
jueves al 8 de la tarde no te vas a ir
al otro lado de la m-30 vas a tener la
cita y gestionó las agendas de todos los
implicados a las 4 de la tarde es verdad
que te voy a fastidiar la siesta es
verdad pero vamos a mejorar muchísimo el
tráfico y si esto es así como estos
científicos afirman de verdad que esto
va a mejorar muchísimo nuestro tráfico y
van a ayudarnos a ganar un montón de
tiempo pero yo los escucho también
intencionados ellos y pienso
realmente los que tienen todos el poder
de gestionar el tráfico estos servicios
públicos van a saber no sólo dónde estoy
sino a dónde voy a van a dónde va todo
el mundo en el futuro en los próximos
días no resulta al menos un poquito
inquietante
pensemos por ejemplo en las cámaras de
seguridad que a veces no nos preocupan a
veces nos preocupan no deberían
preocuparnos tanto porque son muy bobas
sólo se ponen ahí y graban no tienen ni
idea de lo que están haciendo ni de lo
que están grabando pero podemos hacerlas
muy inteligentes podemos ponerles por
ejemplo sistemas de reconocimiento
facial como ya sucede en muchas ciudades
de china de tal manera que la cámara
reconoce quién está pasando delante pero
es más podemos ponerle un software que
sea capaz de interpretar los movimientos
de la gente y así sabría cuando alguien
va a cometer un acto violento o
delictivo podría avisar a la policía a
los otros ciudadanos iluminar al
atacante con una luz potente
si estamos si estamos por ejemplo en un
centro comercial podría cerrar las
puertas para aislar al atacante y abrir
las puertas y las vías de salida para
los demás
todavía más y esto es posible no es nada
difícil podría estar equipada la cámara
con un sistema para lanzar una descarga
eléctrica que inmoviliza al presunto
terrorista podemos [ __ ] la cámara y
ponerlas sobre ruedas y tenemos un robot
de seguridad podemos mejorar la
seguridad muchísimo
sería como tener un policía 24 horas a
nuestro lado pero mucho más barato
y yo me pregunte por qué no tenemos un
policía 24 horas a nuestro lado solo
porque es caro
oa lo mejor no nos apetece tener a
alguien que sabe dónde vamos que sabe
dónde estamos que sabe lo que decimos y
está ahí siguiéndonos día tras día
constantemente no será que a lo mejor
nos hemos esforzado durante siglos para
conseguir que no se genere en este tipo
de estados policiales a lo mejor en
estas cosas tendríamos que pensar
cuidadosamente pero yo hoy quiero
todavía ir un poquito más allá porque
cuando hablamos de ciudades inteligentes
tenemos que tener presente algo
importante y es que pueden ser la mayor
amenaza para nuestra seguridad y la
seguridad de nuestros estados
me intento explicar cuál quieren ustedes
qué es el bien más valioso que hay
actualmente
les voy a dar una pista es el bien más
valioso lo tienen todos además puede ser
que muchos de ustedes lo lleven en el
bolsillo yo lo llevo esto no me moví que
no vale mucho nuestros datos
y no me refiero sólo a que queremos
consumir oa donde queremos viajar que
las empresas se vuelven locas para
conseguir todo esto me refiero a nuestra
intimidad a nuestros secretos aquello
que usted no quiere que los demás sepan
que le da vergüenza a lo mejor no es tan
grave pero aquellos que tienen los
servicios públicos aquellos que tienen
el poder tendrán esos datos podrán
guardarlos y utilizarlos contra usted si
es necesario
miren podríamos decir que los datos son
el mineral más valioso que hay
actualmente más que el oro más que el
petróleo porque si yo tengo los datos de
todos nosotros si tengo los datos de una
sociedad sé lo que está pasando sé hacia
dónde va esa sociedad y es más puedo
incidir sobre ella para hacerla ir donde
yo quiera tener los datos no es solo
poder es el poder total y con el 5 que
hemos superado la frontera la frontera
de la hiperconexión va a haber sensores
por todas partes nosotros compraremos
alexa y la pondremos en nuestra casa
tendremos un coche autónomo llevaremos
el móvil todo lo que hagamos lo que
digamos lo sabrán quienes tienen estos
datos y es más habrá empresas que
necesitan estos datos los necesitan para
gestionar nuestras necesidades básicas
para distribuir los alimentos el agua el
tráfico como decíamos la calidad de
nuestros servicios hasta el vestido
nosotros dependemos de todo esto
saben lo que eso significa cuando un
estado extranjero domine esas empresas
que gestionan en otro país todo eso
imagínense qué sucedería por ejemplo en
caso de guerra
quieren que diga la verdad
no habría guerra si uno hace guerra si
acaso uno hace guerra es para tener ese
poder cuando uno tiene ese poder ya ganó
la guerra
pero bueno no nos pongamos tremendos
vamos aquí viene marcelo a hablarnos de
guerras no
pensemos en nuestra vida cotidiana en
nuestras sociedades en nuestros estados
en españa'
los estados tendrán todos los datos de
sus ciudadanos datos que pueden ser del
tipo que queremos consumir donde
queremos viajar del tipo intimidad pero
hay otros también muy interesantes
qué son aquellas aquellos valores por
los que estamos dispuestos a luchar
aquellos aspectos políticos o económicos
que son para nosotros importantes
aquellas personas a las que amamos y
sabiendo esto y con todos los mecanismos
de manipulación psicológica que la
ciencia pone hoy a nuestra disposición
los estados pueden hacernos pensar lo
que ellos quieran a cada uno de nosotros
a todos bueno a lo mejor no a todos a lo
mejor pueden hacernos que pensemos lo
que quieren a una inmensa mayoría pero
saben que se asegurarán de que esa
inmensa mayoría odia al que piensa
distinto
me está pasando algo así allá y mientras
nos vamos a creer completamente libres
más que nunca porque vamos a consumir
más vamos a viajar más vamos a tener una
vida mejor más socio lo que llamamos
tiempo libre que vamos a ampliar en todo
esto qué es lo que nos digan en lo que
empleemos pero en todo caso nos vamos a
sentir cada vez más libre siempre que
aceptemos ser tratados como marionetas
porque les voy a decir una cosa un
estado totalitario como decía hannah
arendt no necesita comunistas
convencidos ni fascistas convencidos la
gente convencido a la gente que tiene un
criterio mejor o peor para juzgar y
distinguir entre el bien y el mal entre
lo justo y lo injusto no le interesa un
estado totalitario al estado totalitario
le interesa la gente que ha desconectado
de su mente que ha desconectado de su
corazón y de la realidad que sólo le
preocupa que los demás no le juzguen y
seguir el camino que impone la opinión
dominante esa gente es muy fácilmente
manipulable se puede hacer con ella lo
que se desee y saben que lo hará decía
los estados de de los que dependan las
empresas que gestionen esos datos y esos
servicios fijas de no hace tanto había
países pobres que tenían minas y grandes
recursos naturales y las grandes
potencias ofrecían su ayuda para poder
hacerse cargo porque estos países no
tenían la capacidad económica ni
tecnológica para explotar sus recursos
y de esta manera por la ley o de facto
estos países se convertían en colonias y
los ciudadanos en siervos que dependían
de la mano extranjera para poder comer y
así las grandes potencias dominaban la
política la economía la sociedad verdad
hoy lo hemos dicho ya los el mineral más
valioso que hay son nuestros datos y
todos lo quieren y los que van en cabeza
son google amazon facebook
huawei xiaoming de china lo sabe y por
eso está generando su propio sistema de
aplicaciones de geolocalización y
podríamos decir abiertamente su propio
sistema de control social
eeuu también lo sabe está haciendo lo
mismo y yo me pregunto qué hacemos en
españa' que hace la unión europea nos
vamos a conformar aceptamos ser colonias
no vamos a ser capaces de controlar
nuestros recursos porque estamos
hablando
de nuestros ferrocarriles de nuestras
carreteras es decir de los medios de
comunicación del futuro de tener la
capacidad de gestionar nuestro futuro
le voy a decir una cosa a la democracia
no se construyó dejando que otros
hicieran la democracia ha costado sangre
derramada sudor y mucho sacrificio
y nosotros tenemos ahora el reto delante
de nosotros de reconstruir el equilibrio
entre la seguridad la paz la libertad y
los derechos fundamentales no lo va a
hacer nadie tenemos que conseguirlo
nosotros pues que nos conformamos en
vivir en un palacio de cristal donde
vamos a estar cómodos y tranquilos
mientras nos consideran y nos tratan
como animales domésticos de verdad nos
basta con tener en la barriga llena al
teléfono en la mano la televisión
encendida y la cabeza vacía eso es lo
que queremos porque si queremos eso lo
estamos haciendo estupendamente pero si
queremos algo más si queremos mantener
la libertad en nuestras sociedades si
queremos mantener la democracia si
queremos una vida más plena y más
auténtica entonces tenemos que empezar a
correr y tenemos que empezar a correr ya
porque los otros los que quieren
controlar nuestras sociedades los que
quieren hacerse con nuestras almas nos
llevan ya mucha pero que mucha ventaja
[Aplausos]
[Música]